hey if you let's support the production
of more move university video tutorials
then please visit the support move
section on Luke universe comm thank you
and enjoy so next up is the very low
density lipoproteins vldls they are
produced in the Fed states and where
they're produced is actually the liver
so this says this should make sense
think about the functions well let's
talk about what the function is the
function is to deliver endogenous lipids
mainly triglycerides okay so that's here
so it delivers endogenous the [ __ ]
which means these are lipids that are
synthesized in our bodies okay primarily
by the liver so this should make sense
because
time-outs is emphasizing these lipids in
our bodies it's going to be done in the
liver okay why would it be producing the
fed State well in order to synthesize
these endogenous lipids there must have
been an excess in energy consumption we
synthesize lipids when we eat too much
right so let's I'm specifically talking
about when we have too many carbs for
instance people say like if you eat too
much sugar you can store as fat so this
is kind of how that can happen this
occurs in the fed state so if you have
an increase in carb intake you will
produce triglycerides and these
triglycerides that you produce you need
to transport to the storage site the LDL
is the lipoprotein that transports these
analogies they synthesize triglycerides
to the storage sites the April proteins
that are part of the LDL are b100 v 100
c ii and ii okay so let's take a look at
what it looks like with vldls
okay so we talked about it being
synthesized in the
ever write these uh these vldls
so let's kind of zoom in on what's going
on in the liver the liver is going to
make these BL deals are going to be sent
out but let's start with the the carb
intake right so we consume glucose so it
will go into our liver and to go to
acetyl co a co co a can give us fatty
acids these can join glycerol
3-phosphate and they could join
triglycerides to give us these vldls
triple that in orange since I made these
B LDL particles orange and then will be
sent out into the blood as a nascent 2p
LDL particle so if we zoomed in on the
apat asite in the liver we would get
this here so hence these little lines
supposed to be zooming in lines us and I
have had a site in there so we got the
smooth ER making the triglycerides and
we got the rough ER making the a PO be
100 so we're going to have the
triglycerides in the apop 100 come
together in the golgi and eventually
rate at this nation the LDL particle
would be 100 and that's going to be
dumped out into the blood so it only has
that be 100 now and that's because it's
going to get it C 2 and E both from the
HDL particle so the HDL is left with
just a a 1 and the mature VLDL particle
has both the C 2 and the e so the VLDL
is going to transport these
triglycerides circle that different
color and transport these triglycerides
they can be stored in the adipose tissue
or they can be sent to the muscle in the
feds day as well I mentioned up there
just a moment ago that there'd be stored
but they could be used for energy in the
muscle okay
so just like when chylomicrons sent
triglycerides to the muscle in the
adipose tissue the same thing happens we
can have beta oxidation occur here and
the TCA cycle followed by the electron
transport chain the muscle to give us
ATP where the muscle is going to use the
triglycerides for or specifically the
fatty acids that come from the
triglycerides
for energy how did we get those fatty
ass
to begin with well a possi to activated
LPL which is life approaching my face
that cleave these triglycerides into
both the glycerol and the fatty acids
right fatty acids were taken up by the
cells taken up by the adipose tissue and
the muscle tissue so like I said in the
muscle they're used for energy and in
the adipose tissue the fatty acids end
up being stored in triglycerides so
these have store the energy okay and
then we have when this triglyceride from
the VLDL particle this endogenous
triglyceride it's cleaved into the
glycerol fatty acid the glycerol can
head back to the liver okay and the
fatty acids like I said I've taken up by
the by the tissues and then what's left
over from the VLDL is its remnant which
is ideal which we will see in the next
video so thank you for watching thanks
for watching be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and don't forget to share the
video of anyone who you think might find
it helpful thanks and happy studying